みなさんこんにちは阿部雅彦と申します
ペッド talks というと
まあノリノリのお客さんに支えられて塗り鳥のスピーカーが流暢に
楽しそうにそしてすごくいい話をするとそういうイメージがあるかもしれません
しかし今回この子の名のこともあって私はこのようにカメラの前で一人でブツブツ人気
にしゃべるというそういう設定になってしまいました
がっかりしている人もいるかと思います
ただ
せっかくなのであえてこういう
まあ機械でなければなかなか話題にできないようなことをお話ししてみたいなと思って
います
それは帝都 talks そのものを話題にするつまり
言ってみれば今回の聴衆はテントトークそのもの
まあもともと私はちょっとこの点特選キーになることがあったので
その気になることを
今回のイベントでぶつけてみたいとそういうふうに思っています
宜しくお願いします
私は文学の研究をしています
文学の研究者というものは
人が悪ければ悪いほどまあ良いとされている
優れているとされることがあるんですね
でそういう意味では私は人が良すぎてまぁまだまだヒヨッコだなというふうに思ってい
ます
なんでじゃー文学の研究をしている人は人が悪いのかというと文学というのがそもそも
まあみんなが左を向いている時には右を見たり右を向いている時には左を見たいすると
いうようなそういう衝動に支えられているからなんですねまぁ言ってみれば
あまのじゃく
そういうめんどくさい性格をもっていればこそ
文学というものは活性化させることができるというふうに考えられて
まあそのおかげで文学はこう
変な物とか
逸脱したものとか規格に合わないものをすくい上げることができるんですね
だから文学に関わる研究者にしてもまぁサッカーや
自然にしても
例えば人が前を向いている時には後ろをみるとか
人が天を見上げている時にはむしろ
奈落の速うかがうぐらいのそういう気持ちがあるとちょうどいいとそういうことになる
わけですね
で先ほどお話したように鉄盗掘というのはまあ
ノリノリのお客さんの前でノリノリの弁士が流暢にしゃべるというイベントとしてまー
考えられていますけれどもそういう程度とツールば出会えて私は人前でそんなに
ペラペラ上手にしゃべるのが良いことですかという妹をを
まあ問いかけたい
そういうふうに思っています
まあこのところ
人前でペラペラ喋れるのはすごくいいことだという考えが皆さんに共有されていて
例えば中学と高校でもプレゼンの純あの練習という
しばしばさせられますしあるいは
大学の ao 入試なんかでは雄弁にしゃべれる人が確実に有利になります
大学入試の英語でもまぁその延長上なんだと思いますけれども
英語のシャベルテストしようということが伝えられるようになってそこでしゃべる
テストするならそれは民間試験でしょうということで民間試験修行者の方がいい
攻勢をかけて
一気に大学入賞見えがしようって話真ので出てきましたね
まあこの大学入試改革が結局失敗したわけですけれども
ただ皆さん何となく例えば英語ペラペラになったらいいよねっていうような考えは今で
も持っている
でこういう高
まあ例えば英語で言えば
少しでも流暢にしゃべるといいなあという感じ
と人前でしゃべるのはいいことだっていう考えはどちらもおそらく
西洋分解の箱彼らようなものと関係しているんじゃないかという風に私が思っています
がそこで私はあえて
人前でそんなにペラペラしゃべるということが
立派なことですが大事なことですが良いことですかということを問いかけてみたいと
いうふうに思っています
私の父親が元々商社に勤めていて
長らく北米のいくつかの都市で勤務をしていました
でその関係で私も5歳まではカナダのバンクーバーという所に住んでいたんですね
でこの頃は保育園幼稚園に通いそれから近所の友達とも結構パーソンでいたのであの
言葉の中心を英語だったんですよ
ところが日本に帰ってきて環境が一変します全て日本語になってしまう
で
それで面白いのが
この頃のことって殆ど覚えてないんですよ
その前のこと帰国する前のことは覚えているのに何故かその時のことは今日からきれい
でしょう
これはどうもその後両親に聞かされた話ともちょっと関係しているのだなあと思ってい
ます
それどういうことかというとどうもこの時期私がほとんど口をきかなくなって仕事
喋れなくなったって言うんですね
あまり喋らないので心配して病院に連れて行くことだったことだったと聞いています
でまぁ後で聞くと
そういう同じような経験をした人はいるらしくて
まあ環境上げ県してしゃべれなくなってしまったと同時にその時のことをほとんど覚え
ていないとそういうことがやっぱりあると思う
その時に私が思ったのは人間の思考とか記憶というのがすごく言葉に依存しているって
いう
いうことですね
つまり日本に帰ってきたとき私はいやはなく言葉の柱を
英語から日本語にシフトするから得なくなった
ででもしばらくは当然その柱が不安定になるんですね
であの
その結果言葉だけじゃなくて
4 off 4校とか記憶そのものが不安定になってしまったんじゃないか
そういうふうに私は考えているです
まあ
つくづく言葉と心の関係というのはデリケートだなというふうに考えるわけです
さて話はここでは終わりません私は5歳で帰国してまー幼稚園の年中さんに編入したん
ですけれども
その後小学校にすぐでこの小学校に行くときに
まあ家が学区のはずれにあったということもあるんですけれども
登校班というグループでまぁ子供の版
の足で15分から20分くらいですかね歩いてみんなで通っていました
でこの登校班の中で私はほとんどしゃべらない人だ
このころのことはあのすごくよく覚えています
であの
まあ何というでしょうかねその時別にいじめられてたとか嫌なことがあったとか
そういうわけでは全然なくてただあの
私が勝手にしゃべらなかったとで自分でも自分は喋らない人間だなぁと
でもこれはどうしようもないことなんだなあというふうに
意識していたのをこともよく覚えています
でこのような状況はおそらく小学校の3年か4年くらい続いたでしょうかね
で今振り返ってみるとこの状態は明らかに
後6歳のほとんどしゃべらない期間これの延長線上にあったんじゃないかと思い
でこの後正小学校じゃない私のほとんどその英語のフォローアップみたいなことし
なかったので
一旦私の中の英語は根絶されたというでしょうかねほとんどゼロに近くので
なりましたでもそのおかげで日本語が中心となって柱になって
言語的には安定したんだと思います
ただ
この自分がしゃべらない人間であるという認識というんでしょうね
そういう心地というのはその後もずっと残ることになりました
であの
例えば今私はこうしてカメラの前で喋っていますけれども
まあシャベルといえばいわれればしゃべります教員だから当然授業
喋らなきゃできないんですけれども
ただ別に喋らなくてもいいんですね全然問題ないです
で時にはしゃべらない方が楽だなと思うことも今でもあります
私がこうした経験を踏まえていたいのはしゃべれないということを甘く見てはいけない
ということ
もともと言葉の使い方というのはその人の個性が多いに入ってるんですけれども
特にしゃべるということに関しているとその人の一番どうにもならない部分をどう
しようもない部分支えられない部分が
出る可能性が高い
それなのに例えばまあ田子英語のことでいうと5らる英語トレーニングなんかでシャイ
だから喋れないだけさとか
間違いを揃えなければ大丈夫どんどんしゃべろうって言うように曲げ綺麗だけして喋ら
せようとするのはちょっと範囲じゃないかなと私は思っ
しゃべれない人に者無理やり喋らせようとするのは
はっきりかの標的に言うと筋肉とか国家公務れやり引っ張ったり
ねじ曲げたりするのと思いますね暴力的な行為になる可能性
があるんじゃないかというふうに私は考えています
もちろん本当はしゃべりタイムに喋れないという人もいると思いますね
特に英語のことでいうと日本語と英語の構造的な違いのことを守ってまぁあのなかなか
うまくしゃべ
そういう場合はう
きちんと
技術的な問題ですから例えばあの
発音の練習をするとか
リスニングの
鍛錬をするとかあるいはアクセントについてきちんと
システムを学ぶとそういうことをすることである程度はカバーをすることができると
思いますでもそういう時でもとにかくシャイダーだけだからしゃべるバーのやってみれ
ば大丈夫とかまあまあ違いを剃らなければ大丈夫さというふうになんでもかんでも高ま
一瞬の根拠なし
精神論みたいなものを持ち出すのはどうかなと思うんですね
社員に見えることもあるかもしれないけれどもそれは単にシャイなだけとも限らない
つまり日本語とか日本文化のは一種の
ルールというか縛りがあってそのせいでしゃべれないということもあるんですね
なのでむしろそこをきちんと筋3したて説明した上でまぁ
練習して風にすればそういう問題は解決できるんじゃないかなとそういうふうに私は
考えています
さてそろそろ冒頭の通りに戻りましょう
私は先ほどあの問いを立てましたそもそも
人前で上手にしゃべるってそんなに大事なことですかそもそもしゃべるってどういう
ことですか
そういう問いを立てたんですね
でこの問いにあの答えてみたいと思います
まず
喋るというのは言語活動の一部で他の活動と切り離すことができません
でそれからそもそも言語活動というのは人間の精神の土台の部分を出すところで
まあいってみれば人間が人間であるための一番大事な本質的なこところを出すそういう
ものですその一部だけを機に話すのもおかしなことだというふうに私は思います
そうその人と話すと言ってもそこには聞くこととか
黙ることとかそういう要素が入ってきますし
目配せとかジェスチャーとかそれ
相槌とかそれか
呼吸みたいなものの絡んできますね
また喋る時にはこうしゃべりながら考えるとか
場合によっては
躊躇するとか
さらには
感じるとかそういうことも関係してきます
ところが
最近どうも私たちは人前で上手にしゃべることが大事という考えにとらわれずいって
言ってしゃべるという部分だけを
パフォーマンスとしていわばちょくちょ式と切り取って特権化しようとする
そういう傾向があるように
でそのうまくしゃべれる人っていう枠に入る人を
まぁそこにスポッと入ることで
ちょっとしたスーパースターとして扱おうとしたりする
でも例えば点灯 talks で18分間
上手に喋ったからといってそれだけで全人格が折り紙つきになるかというとどうなん
だろうと思うわけです
際には人間は分からないところだらけです
+で多面的です
たとえ上手く喋れてもそこに見えていない部分というものが必ずあります
まあそれ私だってペンとうとう楠根18分喋ってそれですべてだと思われたくないです
ね
第二でも
分からない部分見えない部分っていうのがあると思います
ただ私たちはそういうわからない部分
人間の陰影に満ちたわかりにくい部分っていうのをわかりやすくしたいんだと思うん
ですね
ソースわかりやすく喋ってもらうとまるでその見えない部分が見えてしまう
見えるようになるかのような気がしている
確かにそうすると安心なんですよ何を考えて互換な人っていうのはまあちょっと不気味
で
なんかこう
怖い
下手するとジャーク3歳見えるということがあるかと思います
ただ果たしてそんな風にすべてわかりやすくしちゃっていいんだろうかなという気が私
はしているわけです
そしてもしこのテッド遠くすっていうイベントの中にそういうふうにすべてをわかり
やすくしてしまいたいというような考えが潜んでいるんだとするとちょっと私はそこか
気がかりだなと思うわけで
果たして人間とか世界というのはそんなに
わかりやすく捉えてしまっていいんだろうことそういうギネスがあるか
まあ小説の中にも話し方に特徴があるという人は結構出てきます
つまりその話し方を中心としてその人の人格統計が出されると
ただそういう人は
あんまり年キャラクターとか主人公にならないです
麺キャラクターが主人公っていう人がそのしゃべり方だけを特徴にして
造形されるってこと販売ないと
なんでかというと小川数というもの
まあ土台のところに
人間は表層だけではすべては分からないと言う
まあそういう一種の覚悟みたいなものがあると言う
でそういうことを取って見てだけとってみても諸説というの非常にいまの社会で読む
価値があるもんじゃないかと私は考えています
とはいえこのようにテッド盗掘に対する疑念そのものを
イベントの中に取り込んでしまいる程度トックスっていうのは
朝霞だなあと思う
これはおそらく
テッド talks そのものに
人前でペラペラ喋れるのは素晴らしいっていうような理念だけで推し量らない
まあ何か深いを空気のようなものがあるとそういうことじゃないかと思いますね
まあ今日私がこうやってお話しさせていただいたという子のことがまさにその証拠と
なるんじゃないかという風に
そういう意味では改めて程度とそのものに私は拍手を送りたいとそういうふうに思って
い
実はん
ないと聞いてくださるありがとうございました